on a déjà parlé des coups de soleil mais
il ya une autre très bonne raison de
faire attention au rayon l'été oui le
genre de raison qu'il peut facilement
vous gâcher une journée voire vos
vacances voir votre vie tout l'été des
tc musées d'agde et du siège et les
dangers qui menacent votre bien-être et
votre santé
ils étaient faits à retenir de votre été
alors l'insolation est le coup de
chaleur
je vous parle je suis sûr que oui parce
que ses démons que tout le monde connaît
mais qui regroupe en réalité un certain
nombre de choses dont on n'a pas
forcément conscience et notamment le
fait que ça peut être mortel
[Applaudissements]
ont planté le décor insolation au sens
large du terme
c'est à la fois le fait d'exposer
quelqu'un ou quelque chose au soleil et
les effets de cette exposition dans le
domaine de la santé
évidemment c'est un peu plus spécifique
mais on va voir ça plus tard et un coup
de chaleur c'est une grosse augmentation
de la température du corps causés par
une exposition à la chaleur n'est pas
forcément au soleil une insolation un
coup de chaleur c'est quoi une
insolation c'est l'ensemble des troubles
qui apparaît après une trop longue
exposition au soleil
et quand je dis l'ensemble des troubles
il y en a vraiment pour tous les goûts
oui parce que non seulement il ya plein
de répercussions très différentes sur la
santé mais en plus leur gravité savary
d'un pet de lapin à genre un pet de
gérard depardieu et le plus haut sur
l'échelle du pays c'est l'équivalent de
9 sur l'échelle de richter
les troubles en question ça va des coups
de soleil aux attentes au niveau des
yeux dont on a déjà parlé à la
déshydratation aux maux de tête aux
vertiges voire à la perte de
connaissance et dans les cas les plus
graves
ça peut même aller jusqu'aux troubles
cardiaques les reins peuvent être
sévèrement abîmé des convulsions peut
apparaître et ça peut même aller
jusqu'au coma
ça fait cher la sieste au soleil alors
le coup de chaleur lui il apparaît qu'on
vous rester exposés trop longtemps à une
température élevée parce que votre corps
il n'arrive plus à réguler sa propre
température interne qui monte qui monte
qui monte
du coup l'organisme est en surchauffe ça
commence par un coup de fatigue avec
parfois un peu d'agitation des mal au
crâne
la nausée d'écran que vous ne supportez
plus le bruit ni la lumière votre cou et
votre respiration s'accélère et tous ces
signes peuvent s'aggraver et aller
jusqu'au coma voire pire comment éviter
l'insolation est le coup de chaleur
et oui comme souvent le mieux était de
régler des problèmes avant qu'ils
n'arrivent
alors pour éviter à la fois à
l'insolation est le coup de chaleur
voilà cette règle à respecter quand ça
cogne dur et qu'il fait très chaud et
éviter de rester trop longtemps au
soleil
par exemple si vous faites une fillette
mettez-vous à l'ombre et assurez vous
que vous allez y rester en vous
demandant dans quel sens le soleil va
tourner portez un chapeau ou une
casquette de couleur claire de
préférence pareil pour les vêtements et
choisissez des matières qu'il est
circuler l'air du v 2 à 3 litres d'eau
par jour de l'eau un gentil que l'alcool
ça aggrave les choses
nier vous la tête et la nuque à chaque
fois que vous pouvez et mettez vous
offrait régulièrement
rafraîchissez les pièces dans lesquelles
vous vous trouvez avec des ventilateurs
si vous n'avez pas la clim évidemment ne
fait pas d'efforts physiques intenses
entre 12h et 16h
là où ça tape le plus est de manière
générale évitez de vous exposer à ses
horaires la fête tout particulièrement
attention aux personnes vulnérables
comme les enfants les personnes âgées ou
les gens qui ont une maladie qui défraie
gélules et quand c'est trop tard
on fait quoi que ce soit dans le cas
d'une insolation ou d'un coup de chaleur
les deux priorités c'est rafraîchir et
réhydrater pour la rafraîchir le mieux
dans un premier temps c'est de déplacer
la personne dans un endroit frais
idéalement avec des linges mouillés un
peu partout autour du corps genre ses
vêtements si l on a ou encore mieux des
draps si mauvaise a sous la main
elle est consciente n'hésitez pas à lui
faire boire régulièrement un peu d'eau
fraîche n'est pas glacé
attention c'est là des troubles de la
conscience si elle est dans le pâté
comme on dit communément laisser tomber
un risque de s'étouffer et elle a
vraiment pas besoin de ça et qui allait
carrément inconsciente mettez la en pls
nous soumet commentaires et surveiller
la dans tous les cas a pu mais le 15
même si vous avez un doute la personne
qui vous aurez au bout du fil
déterminera qui il faut vous en voyez
s'il faut vous envoyer quelqu'un et
surtout elle vous dira quoi faire voilà
dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve dans deux semaines pour une
nouvelle vidéo spécialités d'ici là
prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des
autres
méfiez-vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien dans son bois
[Applaudissements]